my grandparents basement had the stairs  they were like old school houses the  house was like 100 years old and he had  wooden steps so the wooden steps were  just plank so you could see right  through  so you know what that is that's a hand  coming out to grab your ankle and drag  you to hell so I would shut the light  off in the basement and then run but I  would do a run almost like a Gazette  like because I would I would like it was  almost like I was doing ballet I would  tip like the the foot couldn't touch the  step for more than like a half a second  and then I'd pull it up high I high  stepped up the steps because you knew  you knew a demon was coming out of there  or a murderer to grab me by the ankles  that's funny man that baby to this day I  do that still I don't like when when  when monsters or anything like that can  take you from these from the steps